good evening
about a hundred years ago
a single generation of physicists their
work caused a radical upheaval
in our understanding of the natural
world our understanding of reality and
it's kind of surprising that you know a
hundred years later
these insights have not been widely
absorbed by
the general public but what is the case
is that our culture has certainly
adopted the language of quantum
mechanics because for instance if we
take a look at things like the quantum
sleeper
every loving couple should have one of
these it gives protection from
biochemical terrorist attacks protection
from natural disasters from kidnappers
stalkers it's a bulletproof safe room
and you just have to sleep inside sort
of like like like dracula um
i'd like to do here tonight though is
just go a little bit further
than the language of quantum physics and
try to give you a sense of
the logical progression of ideas that
led to this new picture of reality that
you saw a little bit about in the
previous video sequence
and then we'll take up some of the
ideas that physicists are still
struggling with today
so what i'd like to do toward that end
is basically look
at a sequence of experiments each one of
which
is pretty simple to describe pretty
simple to explain
but collectively when we go through all
of them we'll come to a pretty startling
conclusion
so the first experiment has to do with a
very simple idea
that many of you no doubt have
experienced you know if you take a a
pebble and you throw it into water
you know that the water will kind of
ripple outwards right now we can create
a version of that experiment same idea
where we have water that's heading
toward a barrier that has a slit in it
and through that slit the water
progresses and you have a radial outward
pouring of the water and on the screen
i'm putting it very bright where the
water is agitated quite vigorously and
then the screen goes darker and darker
you can see from the far left and the
far right because the amount of
agitation gets smaller and smaller as
you get further and further away from
the source of the water namely the
single slit so pretty simple idea just
waves in water
the second experiment
is a simple variation on this one
where i'm going to put a second
slit in the barrier and as you can
picture in your mind's eye and i'll show
you in a moment now what will happen is
you'll have these radial waves emanating
from two places
and the wonderful thing about waves the
real distinguishing feature of waves is
when they cross
something really interesting happens as
you can picture if the peak of one wave
meets the peak of another wave the water
goes higher
if the trough of one wave meets the
trough of another
the water goes lower
but the key thing is if the peak of one
meets the trough of another they cancel
each other out waves can cancel each
other out so they're places where when
the two waves cross the water won't be
agitated at all so let's just take a
quick look at that
here you have the two slits
the water goes through
you have the waves emanating from each
and it's overlapping and on the screen
in the back here i now have placed a
very bright band where a peak in a peak
meet or a trough in a trough but you can
see that there are dark bands that's
where a peak of one wave meets a trough
of another so there isn't much agitation
of the water there at all and this image
that you have right here this
alternating sequence of bright dark
bright dark
this is the telltale signature that you
are dealing with waves
this is the real feature of waves that
they can interfere cancel each other out
yielding those dark bands in between the
bright bands it's as if you had a a row
of little boats back there and each of
them is equipped with a light and
they're going to turn on the intensity
of light to match how much they're being
agitated by the water where it's very
bright they're being agitated a lot
where it's dark
they're not being agitated at all
because that's where the waves are
cancelling each other out so this is the
one
thing that i'd like you to keep in mind
if ever we see in the next few minutes
this kind of pattern
light dark light dark you should
immediately think waves i mean i would
love it if
you know you really took that fully in
so that you know if someone were to wake
you up at three o'clock in the morning
and say i have dark bright dark bright
you say that's waves
and then you should send that person you
know for some help or something like
that but um this is the key message that
is the telltale signature of waves now
i'm going to go through
a few other
quite simple experiments that at first
sight won't
seem to have a direct relationship to
what we just spoke about here but then
we'll bring it all back together in just
a moment so this next version is we're
going to replace the
water by
little bullets little pellets
particles not waves particles let's take
a look at that
so this device over here is just going
to fire some bullets
and as you can see sometimes the bullets
make it through sometimes they don't but
the key thing to look at is when they do
get through
they hit the detector screen
in alignment with the position of the
slits what could be
more simple if they get through they
propagate they travel all the way to the
screen in alignment with the particular
hole in the barrier through which they
passed
so this is what you would expect to
happen if you actually did this
experiment and this is in fact what
would happen but here is the thing
i now want to do a version of this
experiment with one change
i'm going to make the bullet small
really small i'm going to make them
perhaps a billion billion times smaller
than a typical bullet
and i'm going to
use as these little bullets little tiny
electrons
little tiny bits of matter so it's the
same experiment i'm just going to fire
it with these little electrons and what
would happen there
well
this is what you would expect to happen
right at first sight you wouldn't think
that by simply making the bullet
smaller you get anything different
happening so these little tiny electrons
are fired through the slits and this is
what you would think would happen
but when you actually do the experiment
it's not what happens
when you do the experiment
that's what happens
you
get
waves
that is
perplexing at first sight because
where are the waves we just have little
particles
but then
cooler heads can prevail and say you
know what
take a deep breath
if you have water waves water waves are
composed of little h2o molecules
so maybe what's happening is similar to
what happens in water waves the h2o
molecules bang into each other as
they're passing from the source to the
screen maybe these little electrons are
just banging into each other on their
way and that's how
they're creating this interesting
pattern
so what do you do to see if that's the
case
change the experiment a little bit
rather than fire the huge torrent of
electrons all at once
fire them one by one
one by one so let's do that
one by single one fire these guys
and each one lands at some particular
place
on the screen
and if you sit back and you wait
and you wait
dot by single dot on the screen
you in fact build up
that same
pattern that interference pattern which
is the telltale sign of
waves
so we're learning
that somehow
individual particles themselves have a
wave-like character now you could say to
me
you know that's just animation
i could do that
so let me show you the real thing
this is an experiment
done
oh about 10 years ago
which was the first time to really
execute this particular thought
experiment that physicists had
written about and used as a pedagogical
device for many decades these are some
scientists at hitachi
firing electrons at a screen through the
two slits one by one
and watching them build up a particular
collection of data points on the
detector screen now you have to wait a
long time
for you to have enough points to really
see what's going on so luckily for us
we speed this up a little bit and you
can begin to see a little bit of that
telltale sign of waves emerging but it's
still not quite clear it's starting to
come a little bit more into view here
you can begin to see it i hope the
bright the dark the bright the dark
and as it begins to fill in with yet
more of these electrons
the interference pattern
becomes
manifest
so what is this telling us this is
telling us that little individual
particles
somehow have
a wave like character it's telling us
that we really have to think of the
electron as it's traveling from the gun
to the screen
kind of
like a wave so the picture roughly that
begins to come into focus is as the
electron traveling you should think
about it as somehow some kind of wave
and the wave passes through the slits
and the waves overlap just like the
water waves and when they get to the
detector screen
they yield
that interference pattern
now the thing is this raises
a lot of thorny questions
and physicists
from
1920 or so through the 30s really
struggled with this valiantly i mean the
people that i have in mind are people
like you know max plank albert einstein
niels bohr
werner heisenberg
robin williams
that schrodinger up there
doesn't look like robin williams so
these these guys struggled with this for
a long time trying to figure out you
know if the electron is a is a wave
a wave of what what is doing the waving
it's hard to see what that could
possibly be
and it wasn't any of these gentlemen
that figured it out
it was a graduate student
named louis de bruy
who in his phd thesis
came up with the answer and was an
answer for which he would receive the
nobel prize it was the first time in
history
that a phd thesis led and was awarded
the nobel prize and his idea
was this
he said
if i'm watching these little individual
electrons travel from the gun to the
screen and i'm finding them landing in
all sorts of different positions
which fills out this pattern that i know
must be associated with a wave
he had this imaginative leap that the
wave was a wave of
probability
a wave of probability and what he meant
by that was
when the electron is in transit
all you can really say about it is
the probability or the likelihood that
it's here or here or here and when the
wave is big that means there's a high
probability
that the particle is there when the wave
is small there's a low probability that
it would be there and that means if you
fire a lot of these electrons over and
over again
the way in which the land on the screen
is dictated by that probability profile
where the overlapping waves are big
you'll get many electrons where the
overlapping waves are small you'll get
very few electrons so if you go back to
this little picture
here is the wave of probability
it overlaps with itself
having places where the wave is big
or small and where the wave is big a lot
of electrons will land there because
there's a high probability that they
will but where the waves cancel out
very few or no electrons will land
giving rise to the telltale pattern
bright
dark
bright dark
of waves
that's
the most astounding
moment
at least to my mind in the history of
our species
we thought from the time of newton that
the universe was very much like a clock
right that was the metaphor that newton
liked to use the universe is just sort
of wound up you let it go and it evolves
and you can predict with absolute
certainty how it will look at any given
moment if you know how it is at previous
moments
but this tells us that that's not how
the world works
even if you know how things are
precisely or as precisely as possible
there's an element of probability that
comes into the story there's only a
likelihood of things turning out one way
or another and the discussion that we
will have in just a few minutes we're
going to probe this idea try to tease it
apart and really see what it's telling
us about the nature of reality but
there's one question that i'd like to
quickly address first which is the most
natural question to ask
if the world
is fundamentally probabilistic if all
you can say is the electron might be
here or here or here and if the laws
tell you the probabilities of it being
at those locations but that's the best
you can do
where does the definite world that we
know about come from
right i mean
you all probably think i'm here
i think it too
so where does this definite reality come
from and i'd like to just begin to
address that question we'll talk about
it more in the panel but to address it
what i'd like to do is just compare
what the probability wave associated
with a small particle like an electron
how that compares with the probability
associated with something large like me
or a baseball so to do that i'm going to
imagine that i have an electron and i
and i put it here
say on a table if you will and i let it
go now just before i let it go
i know where the electron is with
absolute certainty it's right here which
means the probability wave must be
really big over here and really small
everywhere else
and i'm going to show you a picture of
that just a little cartoon of it in a
moment you'll see a very spiked looking
shape
and that is indicating the position of
the electron so let's take a quick look
at that and then i'll let the electron
go and watch what happens to the
probabilities so if i give that a whirl
there's some probability that these
devices don't work
uh i did the calculation earlier and
thought i was in good shape but let's
give it a there we go so the probability
started spiked
but then it spreads out right now the
electron could be at any of these
locations with the size of the wave
telling us the likelihood that it's
there but then if we look
and we measure the electron we always
find it in one place or another we never
find sort of a third of an electron here
or half of it there when we do the
measurement somehow in a way that we'll
discuss later
the probability the fuzzy probabilistic
haze collapses
to a definite reality every time you
look the electron says i'm being looked
at i better choose one location or
another and it does
how it does that is still pretty
mysterious now if we now allow the
electron to go again
so we stop looking at it if you will
it jumps around its probability profile
quickly spreads out
so the key feature of an object like an
electron is that you may be able to say
at a given moment where it is
but after you stop looking in some sense
the probabilities all spread out until
you look again and that's the nature of
quantum mechanics for small objects now
let's look at a big object like a
baseball
for a baseball the probability doesn't
spread out for a human being it doesn't
spread out so where the baseball is
according to newton and where the
baseball is according to quantum
mechanics coincide
the probabilities are highly skewed
there's a huge probability that the
baseball is where newton would think it
is and it never spreads out so baseballs
and people and everything in the world
around us has the character that it does
because these probabilities
stick together and have an
overwhelmingly large size where somebody
like newton would have thought those
probabilities would be now i just want
to point out one thing you may have
noticed
as the ball was traveling and as the
probability profile was traveling with
it that sometimes the upper hemisphere
of the ball separated from the lower did
you see that couple yes and the same
thing sort of happened with the the
probability profile sometimes it would
break apart
this is a very interesting puzzle not
one that you really could ask einstein
or bohr or heisenberg about
this particular puzzle is one that you
have to ask bill gates
so i just want to end this presentation
by noting the following thing
the scientists who came up with these
ideas struggled valiantly to try to
reconcile their intuition about the
world an intuition that's built up from
everyday experiences where things seem
so definite
things seem so
manifestly here or there without
probabilities they tried dietly to
reconcile their intuition with what was
emerging from the experiments and the
theorizing and just to give you a sense
of the struggles that these
individuals went through werner
heisenberg and won the nobel prize in
1932 said i remember discussions with
boar which went until very late at night
and ended almost in despair
and when at the end of the discussion i
went alone for a walk in a neighboring
park i repeated to myself again and
again can nature possibly be as absurd
as it seemed to us in these experiments
another nobel prize winner
who won the prize in 1914
max finlao he said if it turns out to be
true i'll quit physics
and finally
the master himself albert einstein
later in his life he said i still
believe in the possibility of a model of
reality which represents things
themselves and not merely the
probability of their occurrence and
we'll talk about this
idea a little bit later on but what we
seem to have found from experiments and
from theorizing
is that there is an unavoidable element
of chance
in the way
the world
changes from moment to moment there is
an unavoidable
element of probability in the laws of
physics the universe evolves
in some very real sense
according to a throw
of the dice
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so from groucho marx to niels bohr it's
hard to get
pretty much uh all of us think so but
for the next hour we're going to be
talking
to some experts who who do get it to a
great extent i assume
and we'd like to hear a little bit about
what you get and maybe you can inject us
with it infect us with your uh getting
of it
we'll be talking with max tegmark who is
a renowned cosmologist and in his spare
time is a proponent of the many worlds
interpretation of quantum mechanics and
that says that if quantum mechanics says
there's more than one outcome of any
action then it will happen in worlds
other than the one we're aware of do i
have that roughly right
in this universe you have it right
you can't count the ones in which i have
it wrong
and bill phillips as a quantum physicist
who you could say is working in the
trenches he manipulates atoms so that
they can be used for different
applications like atomic clocks and in
1997 he won the nobel prize for his work
david albert is a philosopher
david albert is a philosopher who was
also a physicist himself and he is
renowned for his insights into the
thorny philosophical questions raised by
quantum mechanics and brian greene as
you know
works on string theory and it's a it's
an effort to bring quantum mechanics and
gravity together something i've always
longed for myself
so here's the thing the way i'm i'm just
wondering why it's so hard for us maybe
it's hard for us because
we've been
we've evolved in in such a way that
we're adapted
to seeing the world
only the way that's useful to us at
least up until now uh there is there is
we don't see the billions of
of microbes on our arms i mean there are
a lot of a lot of parts of our reality
that that's invisible to us it might
have an effect on us we might get sick
from it but we don't see them except
with instrumentation we don't see
except lately in the last uh
century or so we don't see outside of
the range of light that we've uh that
we're adapted to
and it affects us we're affected by
ultraviolet rays and that kind of thing
but but
we don't pay attention to it most of the
time
is it possible that that the quantum
world exists um
and may you know not only affect us but
we are it
but we don't we're not adapted to to
paying attention to it
uh
maybe it's with your machines and your
theories you can see it and we can't
and
and we somehow need to bridge that gap i
mean just take this first thing
uh
brian was showing us on the screen
uh the wave the two slit experiments
with the waves
so this whole idea of a probability wave
you know when these electrons are fired
they're single electrons right and
they're fired so let me ask max you're
the expert closest hand to me right in
this minute
we think of that now as a probability
wave
is that a real thing or is that uh is
that a mathematical construct
well
the the
most important thing you're going to
learn tonight is that
even today a century after this
theory was first pioneered you get
experts on stage will disagree
passionately about the answer
i'm i'm chosen to be the fall guy i hear
i think the the minority who
thinks that their
probabilities are just an illusion and
uh let me explain why i think that what
seems to us is random
is really
not random and it has to do with cloning
so let's forget for a moment all about
quantum physics and let's
sedate you
you go to sleep and while you're
sleeping i'm going to use some
nanotechnology but i think some people
in the audience are already there when
i wasn't that guy in the back
and uh you're going to date me now i'm
going to i'm going to measure where
every atom in your body is and build a
perfect copy so you have two allens and
i'm gonna
and then i'm gonna wake one of you up
right here on stage and the other allen
is gonna wake up in washington square
park okay
and both of them are gonna have exactly
the same memories of this discussion the
sedation right so if i ask you now which
of those two allens are you going to be
if i ask you specifically where are you
going to wake up
you can't
it's going to seem
this one island is going to feel you
randomly woke up and washington square
park the other one is going to be
randomly woke up here there's no way for
you now to predict
where you're going to wake up because
both copies are going to wake up
somewhere right
and the parallel universe interpretation
of quantum physics which we're going to
argue about
says exactly that that's what's
happening
you were effective of being cloned you
were the little part of it's not just
the little particles
that were made of that can be in two
places once brian very nicely showed how
an electron can go through two slits at
the same time but since we are made of
these particles
we too
can be in multiple places at the same
time and you can be here and in the park
at the same time okay let me let me ask
you a question about this before other
people uh rush over and choke go for my
junk
when when uh when you say um that you
can't that the
that these particle that the wave the
the
the wave the wave probably the wave
function is not a real thing
um
are you are you saying that these these
particles are are splitting off and
going into other worlds or or or not i
mean they're coming out of this electron
gun and they're going through two slits
so what's happening i mean it didn't
sound like you explained what was
happening so and like you went into this
other thing
so
the one thing we all agree about is how
we should calculate the math and the
math just says there's this curve which
brian showed nice plots of now brian
called it a probability wave that's
where it gets contentious
whether you interpret it as a
probability or something else usually so
we don't fight so much we have a
different name for it we call it the
wave function okay it's a curve okay so
in other words you're not you're saying
that it's not a
probability it's just a mathematical
thing we all agree how to calculate it
and then
brian showed a beautiful animation
of how this can spread out for little
things and he said that for big things
it doesn't spread out
but
the problem is that
ervin schwerettinger pointed out that
you can actually devise experiments
where even this wave function for big
things also spreads out he's pointed out
that if you take a cat
and then you build a horrible little
device which kills the cat or not
depending on what just one atom does
then afterwards the whole cat
is going to have very spread out one of
these curves and be doing two very
different things so it turns out we
can't
confine this quantum weirdness to the
micro world of the small it can it
spills out
and
caused all this wonderful confusion well
as i said they would explain it all to
you
[Laughter]
so now what's your take on this well my
take is is very different from from
max's max has um
a very interesting but not entirely
orthodox uh view about this and i'm i
fall into the more more conventional and
orthodox uh point of view the same one
that uh that niels bohr
uh took
and so so to understand what my take is
on this let me just uh back up a little
bit and talk about this two-slit
experiment again because it's it's a
wonderful experiment so you shoot an
electron at these two slits
and what quantum mechanics tells us is
there's no way that we can tell where
that electron is going to end up but
it's going to end up someplace when we
when it hits the screen it's going to
make a flash of light and we can tell
where it is but beforehand there's no
way of telling if you shoot a gun you
can tell where the bullet's going to hit
but if you shoot an electron you can't
now the problem is how to make sense of
that if that electron is really uh
a real object and the way max likes to
make sense of it is that in one universe
it goes there and in another universe it
goes there in another universe it goes
someplace else
and the way niels bohr makes sense of it
is to say you're not allowed to ask that
kind of question
that's the orthodox point of view in
quantum mechanics such a question is
meaningless the only thing that's
meaningful is what is the result of the
measurement and so
uh you can calculate what the
probability distribution is and we all
agree on how to calculate what we don't
agree on is how to make sense of that
how to interpret the calculation how to
say what does that calculation mean so
max says the calculation means that
there's this distribution of all these
gazillion different uh worlds in which
the different things happen and my
interpretation is
and
[Laughter]
in the end i measure something and the
probability of getting that result and
if i do it again i'm going to get a
different measurement and after a great
number of measurements that we saw
illustrated on that that video it's
going to build up exactly the
probability distribution so we like to
call that interpretation the shut up and
calculate interpretation meaning all
this stuff about many worlds you know it
doesn't matter in the end i know how to
do the calculation max knows how to do
the calculation we get the same answer
and when we go into the lab we get the
same results and whether i accept max's
result or whether i accept the shut up
and calculate answer i get the same
answer now i'm well let me ask dave
albert because i i sense you're you're
treading on dave albert's toes okay a
little bit
how do you feel about that that that if
if you just shut up and calculate are
you missing anything are you missing any
of the fun in life yeah um
[Music]
yeah it seems to me it seems to me
you're missing much of it um um
probably all of us initially got
interested in science
because we wanted to know what was going
on
so
there ought to be a resistance it's
proper for there to be a resistance
to someone who tells you that there are
certain sorts of questions
you're just not supposed to ask
nobody nobody is born and opens their
eyes with an intrinsic interest in how a
particular experiment is going to come
out or how to do a particular kind of
calculation the kind of interest we come
to the world with i think
is an interest in what's going on
and if it's really the case
that there are certain questions about
what's going on
that it turns out to be inappropriate to
ask
it seems to me right to regard that as
an enormous disappointment
of the whole scientific project
and so in this respect um in this very
broad brush respect i guess i'm i'm
closer to max um um
i'm i'm interested in in trying to
figure out what's going on in trying to
be able to tell a story of why it is
that these experiments come out as they
do rather than just
having a method
which might as well be close your eyes
and say abracadabra or something like
that
for calculating
how they come out i think
that the particular story
that max is enthusiastic about
is a story that seems to me to have a
lot of problems the problem isn't that
it's wacky it's pretty clear that the
world is
wacky
i think there's a useful distinction to
be made here
it's pretty clear that that
the subatomic world is strange one way
or another no matter how you
cut it
um
the important distinction is
whether
it's merely strange or whether it's
strange in such a ways to make it
literally unintelligible
whether the world is stranger than we
know or stranger than we can know okay
um
the worry about the many worlds
interpretation i think maybe maybe i can
be a little bit more concrete about this
um
the the reason we have for believing in
quantum mechanics in the first place
the the hard evidence that we have that
something in the neighborhood of quantum
mechanics is true has to do with
observing statistics of repeated
measurements on similar systems okay
the kinds of experiments that brian was
talking about
before the worry about the many worlds
interpretation
is that
it's not gonna it's not gonna be able to
account since it's an interpretation
that says everything happens for sure
it looks like it's to be at a loss to
account for
why we observe these particular
frequencies as opposed to those
particular frequencies while we observe
these particular statistics of outcomes
of measurements as opposed to those
particular statistics of outcomes of
measurements when we repeat a a
measurement a bunch of times because the
many worlds interpretation says
all of those statistics are going to
occur
for sure okay
here's a slightly different way to put
the worry um
quantum mechanics has these
probabilities at the bottom of it which
we've been talking about and the kind of
the the reasons we have for thinking
quantum mechanics is true are precisely
that the kinds of statistics we observe
when we do these experiments are the
kinds of statistics that these
probabilities say are the statistics we
ought to let me pick you up on that
let me ask brian too because that's a
very interesting question
those of us on the outside of this
mysterious realm that you people study
so assiduously
we hear about how it works on chance and
it sounds a little fuzzy to us
and yet brian isn't there
an accuracy in quantum mechanics that's
uh that's amazing yeah i mean quantum
mechanics is the most accurate theory
that has ever been written down
by a long shot
but what it's accurate about is
unfamiliar right so it used to be in the
time of newton that if you want to know
where a baseball will land you use the
laws that newton wrote down and they
predict exactly where the ball will land
so that's the kind of data that you use
to support newton's view of the world
quantum theory says that's just
wrong-headed
quantum theory says what you should be
predicting are the likelihoods the
probabilities of the ball landing here
or here or here and if the math says
that the ball will land 30 percent
chance here 30 percent chance here and
40 percent chance here then do the
experiment 100 times and if it turns out
that 30 times more or less it lands
there 30 times more or less it lands
here and 40 times more or less it lands
there
then you're confirming
the probabilistic predictions of the
theory now this example with a little
ball is one particular one that i just
cooked up in order to explain the basic
idea but when it comes to particles like
electrons you can do a quantum
mechanical calculation of a property of
the electron
its magnetic properties the details
don't matter at all the calculations are
extraordinarily difficult it took a
group of physicists more than 30 years
to do the calculations but by the end of
the calculation they had a number that
emerged from quantum mechanics two point
whatever ten decimal places long they go
out and they measure that particular
magnetic property of the electron
and digit by digit by digit
ten decimal places long
it agrees
with
the prediction
that tells you that you're on to
something
it's unusual but you're on to okay so
given that incredible degree of accuracy
why was it
why why did so many
great physicists have problems with this
especially in the beginning let me ask
you bill yeah well
first of all let me say that i want to
amplify what what what brian said about
that kind of accuracy there's those two
sides of quantum mechanics on the one
hand you predict only probabilities for
the outcome of a result but on the other
hand
it's incredibly
powerful in predicting the the exact
value of certain kinds of properties and
i'm particularly glad you brought that
one up because i actually had something
to do with that measurement and
it's an extremely satisfying thing when
you do this yeah and it comes out the
way the theory predicts
but you know even more satisfying is if
something comes out different
from the way why why predicts because
it's so much more exciting because you
learn something new if all you ever do
is have a theory and uh you always
make your measurements and you find out
that the the measurements agree with
what the theory predicts you haven't
learned anything new
now in fact the the thing that brian was
talking about the strength of the
magnetic field of an electron
early on in the history of quantum
mechanics people thought they knew how
to predict it and they did and until
people started making really careful
measurements
they thought they had it right when they
started making measurements a little bit
more carefully they found out
it's not coming out quite right and they
learned something new about the theory
as a result
so now um
dave is talking about uh the excitement
of uh of understanding reality well
there's a there's another kind of
excitement in learning something new
and even when that learning something
new is a new mathematical theory that's
incredibly exciting and that's what
happened when uh this new uh idea that
what we call quantum electrodynamics
that was added on to quantum mechanics
that allowed you to do this incredibly
accurate uh calculation that brian
talked about now
the darn thing is that it works so well
that every time we make a measurement
we get just what the theory predicts
it's kind of disappointing
because
you know the really exciting i had no
idea quantum mechanics was so boring
but one prediction after another to get
back
but but get back to your real question
why did people resist it so much such
smart people well
einstein
one of the smartest people that ever
lived
couldn't buy quantum mechanics he just
didn't like it he said famously that i
can't believe that god plays a dice with
the universe and that's why we had the
uh
the the the dice
dance
and i think
well
he not he not only was against dice he
was in favor of dancers uh you had a
point as i'm sure he was well and i
think that it's just what you were
alluding to at the beginning it flies in
the face of everything that we
understand from our ordinary experience
in our ordinary experience
things aren't in two places at the same
time in quantum mechanics they are
in our ordinary experience uh
you know something is here or it's there
cats are either alive or they're dead
they're not both at the same time
and
now in max's world the cat's alive in
this world and the cat's dead in the
other world and there's there's no
problem for max
einstein there was a big problem because
they
couldn't buy this idea that a cat could
be both alive and dead at the same time
until we looked at it
but the amazing thing is that every
prediction that this weird theory makes
about the way the world works has been
verified and and it is just the way the
world works in other words
einstein was absolutely right to say
that quantum mechanics is just horribly
weird impossibly weird
and it turns out that that's the way the
world is
now but it's not important i think that
they want it to be otherwise i think
there's a distinction that's worth
that's worth making here
um
if i can jump in
it's one thing
to be surprised that the world turns out
to be this way or that way somebody says
the world turns out to be this way you
say that's very odd that's unlike my
everyday macroscopic experience that's a
surprise to me
so on and so forth it seems to me the
right answer to that
is to say too bad for you
nature wasn't designed to make you
comfortable nature wasn't designed to be
familiar so on and so forth i don't
think
it's exactly that that was the nature of
einstein's objection there's something
there there's another situation
that's much more serious than that okay
it's not merely the world's being
strange if somebody tells you the world
turns out to be chancy as opposed to
deterministic seems to me the right
thing to do is to suck it up okay and to
say well that's not what i expected but
uh
but
i'm going to have to think about it i'm
going to have to get used to it i'm
going to have to learn to live with it
it's a very different story to be told
something like an electron is
a probability wave okay or an electron
is probability or something like that
that is
that's a statement more i don't know if
somebody picks up this bottle of water
and they say look my theory is based on
the idea that this bottle of water is
elvis presley
um
the right reaction to this is not i
didn't think that was true
but
i don't know what you mean okay
um that's the position a lot of people
that's right i don't know what idea it
is that i'm being asked to get used to
here okay i don't know
i don't know what it would mean
to entertain the possibility even if i'm
later going to reject it that this
bottle of water is elvis presley okay i
just don't get that okay um um this and
i i think it's really important
to make a distinction between
something being strange and something
just being unintelligible okay um
um if if you're if you're you know if
you're pouty because the world is
strange
that's too bad for you okay um but if
somebody tells you a story that says
you're gonna be able to understand
everything if you can just get your head
around the fact that this bottle of
water is elvis presley um the right
answer is i just don't know
our recent history is full of situations
in which we've been astonished to find
out that a little box in the corner of
the room
had milton berle on it and in fact elvis
presley
when everybody knew he was in tennessee
at the time
so
not to say that therefore anything is
possible but we are permissible
totally reversed in our thinking if we
want to play this game one step further
i know i'll then i'll shut up
i guess there i guess there are things
one could imagine meaning by this bottle
of water is elvis presley i don't know
the adams and elvis presley's body
reformed themselves into this bottle of
water um something like that okay but
that's not like the quantum mechanical
case it's not the guy you'll say to the
guy is that what you mean the guy says
no no no i don't mean that i don't mean
this bottled water came from elvis
presley i don't mean this bottle of
water is the remains of elvis presley i
mean this bottle of water is elvis
presley don't you see
and you have to say no i i don't
okay now now max here is jittering like
the quantum soup so i want to find out
i would find out what's on your mind
yeah i was just eager to jump in and
defend einstein a little bit not elvis
i'm not going to defend elvis presley
don't worry since he was being somewhat
picked on i have a
minority view that einstein was actually
correct in his objection yeah i agree
with that there really is nothing random
and
and um
to me really the the
key question rather is just how big is
really the ultimate reality you know
if you know an ostrich sticks its head
in the sand
it's going to think that reality is
somehow smaller than it really is right
and we humans also have a bit of this
hubristic tendency we have again and
again
assumed that reality is smaller than it
was just so we could feel more important
we used to think the solar system was
basically a reality and and then we say
oh actually the galaxy that's it
and then even when my grandma was a kid
you know they still didn't even realize
there were other galaxies so we've had
to expand our horizons and accept that
there's more to it than we thought now
we know that there are many other solar
systems and so on and i don't think
there's any reason whatsoever to assume
that
even beyond what we now call our
universe
the domain that we can see there's
probably still more space going on
and
when we physicists talk about the
quantum reality you know we're a bunch
of nerds we talk about math because as
galileo said
nature
is really
a book in the language of mathematics
and this math describes a reality
which is even bigger than the one we can
see this quantum reality has a fancy
geek name called hilbert space right and
then there's only one
reality this hilbert space it's just
that hilbert's space is huge in this
reality you can have
a planet like earth being in several
places at once which is what we mean by
by these parallel universes and then
there is this equation discovered by
schroedinger so it's called the
schroedinger equation which just tells
you if you have this reality here's what
it's going to do in the future it's very
analogous to what the
describing of brian about the baseball
you know where the baseball is you know
how it's moving so you can figure out if
it's going to be a home run or not
if you know what's going on in hilbert
space right now you can figure out the
future
the only this you're talking about
newton's version
if you know where the baseball is and
what force is applied to it you'll know
what's going to happen exactly
but now you agree you can't do that with
with these particles no you can predict
what all of hilbert space is going to do
again but the problem is
that you start with a situation in
hilbert space where
uh phillips is in one place and then you
do a little shredding your cat
experiment on them or something
and you solve the equations i still know
what the whole hilbert space is doing
the whole reality but the new reality
now has you being in two different
places i think i think brian feels we're
in dilbert space
so i think einstein would actually
feel more at peace with this notion
because at least there's nothing really
random it's just that we're being cloned
well let me let me go back to something
that i just i'd like to get back to
earth for a second
uh
you talked about uh that in our
experience and it's similar to what i
was saying in the beginning we're we're
used to things uh being in one place at
one time but that can we kind of feel
comfortable with that
and yet you have entanglement mm-hmm
brian why don't you walk us through
entanglement a little bit because it's a
there's that's one of the great
weirdnesses of the quantum world sure
i'm happy to uh the timing's a little
awkward because i just put a cough drop
in my mouth but
you know what's amazing is i now have
one in my mouth
anyway
it's in both places at once in hilbert's
place you know earlier today we got
entangled in the elevator and
so you know we've heard you know a lot
about the weirdness of quantum mechanics
being the need to take on this idea that
all you can do is predict probabilities
or likelihoods
but actually quantum weirdness is far
more perplexing than that
so what i'd like you to do at least for
the next minute
is accept this idea that probabilities
govern how the world evolves and let's
take it to the next step which emerged
from work of einstein with two
colleagues podolski and rosen
this work emerged from the fact that
einstein as we heard didn't really like
quantum mechanics so he's studying it
try to find something that was like
wrong with it or something that would
establish to the people who were
proponents of it that it wasn't right or
was incomplete and here's what he came
up with and let me describe it if you
will
in two stages and i'm saying this
because david is sitting over here and
the first stage will not quite be
accurate but it'll be a little bit
easier to take on board don't jump on me
i'll then correct it and make it a
little bit more precise
so entanglement what einstein fan was
you could have particles well first of
all let me just emphasize one thing
particles can have a property
known as spin particles can kind of spin
around like a top and if they spin say
counterclockwise we say they're spinning
up and if they're spinning clockwise we
say they're spinning down so they can be
spinning up or they can be spinning down
einstein his colleagues found that you
could have two particles
set them up in such a way that each of
them is in this funny mixture of both
spinning up and spinning down fifty
percent chance of each that's the
weirdness of quantum mechanics fifty
percent up fifty percent down and you
can set them up so that they're both in
this mixture half up half down
and you can take one of these particles
put it in a box
bring it way over here say in new york
take the other particle put in another
box bring it over to california so here
they are each in this fuzzy mixture of
both spinning up and spinning down you
go over to the box in new york and you
open it up
and as we were discussing earlier the
particle snaps to attention say it snaps
up it knows it's being looked at
measured
what einstein and his colleagues found
from the math was
it said that at the very moment that you
open the box in new york and find it
spinning up
the one in california also snaps to
attention spinning down even though
it's three thousand miles away you
didn't do anything to it in the reverse
experiment go over to the one in
california open the box and say it's
spinning up at that moment the mass says
the one in new york should spin down
even though there's no connection
between them einstein called this spooky
spooky action at a distance you do
something over here and it somehow
affects something over there and his
hope in some sense was that this was
such a crazy implication of quantum
theory that if the people who were in
favor of it learned about this feature
they'd say oh there must be something
wrong
now when he showed this to people like
bohr
they did
run around a little bit at first a
little perplexed and they basically said
maybe that's just how things actually do
work
how could you tell well you wanted to
actually do the experiment you know this
is just math at the moment you couldn't
do the experiment in the 30s when this
was really put forward 40s 50s 60s 70s
you can do it by the 80s you could do it
and people did the experiment and just
as quantum theory predicted this guy
spins up that guy spins down this guy
spins up that guy's pins down at a
distance at what distance the experiment
was done were they over 11 kilometers
they didn't
there's no reason why it couldn't be
people could one could one could be here
on the stage and another could be on
mars and it'd be in the other end of the
universe and it's as if these two
particles have a quantum entanglement
that's where they're here's the here's
the amazing thing to me about that
not just that it exists but that you can
take it and do something with it
what can you do with that
ah what can we do with it
one of the things we can do with that
idea of entanglement is make money
make money
maybe somebody
there may be a time when somebody does
make money what we can do is we can make
a new kind of computer a kind of
computer that nobody ever even thought
about
or could have even thought about before
there was quantum mechanics but this
computer can solve problems
that are essentially impossible for even
the fastest imaginable
ordinary bill gates type computer
to do so there are problems that are so
hard that not just the fastest computers
of today but the fastest computers we
could even imagine building cannot solve
within our lifetime now briefly how
would you take uh the spooky action at a
distance
and turn it into a computer just roughly
how would you do it so the idea is that
as we know as many of us know at least
information is stored in our computers
is what we call bits
a bit is either zero or one and we
represent that by say a spot on our
cd-rom that's either burned or not
burned now in the quantum world the bit
is called a qubit for a quantum bit and
the zero and one is up or down the spin
being up or down
now the cool thing is
that if i have
uh one bit it can either be up or down
and um
that's that's all either up or down
quantum mechanically it's a plus or
minus binary right but quantum
mechanically both up and down at the
same time
okay so you got both possibilities well
that's great now let's say i've got two
of them
now if i've got two ordinary bits
they could be either both up or both
down or one up and one down and or the
other way around
one of four different possibilities well
with quantum mechanics it could be all
four possibilities at the same time
now with three bits
there's eight different possibilities
and in quantum mechanics you have all
eight at the same time
now let's say i had 100 bits which is
nothing strange you've got billions of
bits in all of your computers let's say
i just had 100 bits
okay
then
the number of different possibilities
that i could have all at one time with
quantum mechanics if i allow them to be
entangled
is more than the number of particles in
the entire universe
so you're saying with only a hundred
bits
you would have i'd say it's 300 but
never mind okay
i made a little error
that's uh i mean that's
minuscule that's right and that gives
you in a way a computer equivalent to
the brain power you'd find if every bit
and every particle in the universe was
was a bit in your computer it means that
you can do
more calculations at one time in other
words all those possibilities are stored
in the quantum computer at one time so
you can do in parallel more calculations
than there are things in the entire
universe that's a power that we can
never realize with ordinary bill gates
type computers so that's where
entanglement can really produce
real results so this thing that was like
i imagine in building this computer you
have a problem because every time you
try to access it you're looking at it
and kind of messing it up yeah so you've
got to be careful never to look at it
no i'm serving this follows my theory of
current computers that you can do
anything with the computer and it'll
never break down as long as you don't
use it well
yeah well it's an analogous idea
it seems
it seems like there's a spectrum to me
it does anyway of of of interpretations
ranging safe from niels bohr
on once one end of the spectrum who felt
that the
getting from
the quantum world to the classical world
that there was a discontinuity that you
reached a barrier everything you could
measure things in the quantum world but
then when you want to measure baseballs
and us you had to jump over that barrier
now you're in a new world new new rules
new game and don't ask why just calculus
do it you know then on the other end of
the spectrum you have things like an
agent that takes care of everything and
decides what's going to or you have max
who says
is it it all happens everything happens
it's not a probability right
it's not like this could happen
everything does happen and only it
happens in worlds that were not right
these worlds are not out there
necessarily right they're they're like
all mixed together right so i'm really
interested to to to hear where where you
think we are in this in this spectrum do
you is it is it necessary to stake out
territory along that spectrum or or can
you be open to all these possibilities
at the same time or all these realities
at the same time
and which end do you want to start
closest to denmark
well
i don't even know where you guys are on
this i mean
i maybe i can start that there
there's
i think the right thing to do of course
is to be
is to be open-minded about this we have
several
ways of trying to make sense that is we
have several ways of trying to get
beyond
the shut up and calculate
attitude
and as a matter of fact some of these
ways make
different empirical predictions than
than one another and these are being
developed these are new scientific
theories there are a bunch of i think
very promising ones on the table um
and people are studying these and people
are trying to parlay them into concrete
predictions that we can then come and do
experiments about and it's being turned
back into an ordinary scientific problem
which i think is is is the right thing
to do with it it is
um
there is a let me let me say a little
about what what
um brian said about entanglement um
before brian was expecting me to
disagree with him and i will a little
bit well actually i had a part two that
i never got to but like okay good so
maybe this is part two yeah
look
what
einstein pointed out um
this
non-locality um this phenomenon of
entanglement um it's not exactly true
that his attitude was as soon as people
hear about this
they're gonna say oh it's crazy and
they're going to abandon quantum
mechanics he thought he had a strict
logical argument okay that if you made
certain assumptions that sounded
plausible he had a proof from this
phenomenon of entanglement that quantum
mechanics must be incomplete as a
description of what's really going on
and
bohr's reaction to it
was and boy's reaction to it was an
interesting curiously philosophical
reaction to a very concrete scientific
argument
board didn't say well
if that's what the equations say that's
what's going on
bohr if you read his response to the to
the einstein podoski rosen argument
essentially says something like you know
this word
really what's really going on
i don't like that word so much
um that's kind of old-fashioned
it's a little bit nerdy to be to be
all all in a fuss about knowing what's
really going on
um it's time to get it's time to get
beyond that um it's time to
it's time to
to learn
that there are certain kinds of
questions about what's really going on
that it's naive or old-fashioned or
archaic or somehow so but where are you
where are you along the spectrum i'm i'm
with einstein on this spectrum um those
are the only questions at the end of the
day worth asking
and i'm not in the mood to learn
that
you know this notion of reality you know
who really cares about that and uh
and so on and so forth um yeah i think
once again something that max and i are
completely in agreement on here
um
um is those are the questions to ask
bohr made
i guess the best word were made very
oracular sorts of pronouncements
um it you know it seems that the the the
further along we get in thinking and
experimenting
am i right about this i get the
impression that
the quantum world keeps creeping more
and more into the the big world that
we're comfortable with you can you seem
to be able to
to determine things about bigger things
right yeah through understanding these
small that's absolutely right yeah so so
that seems like that that spectrum is uh
spreading out mushing out this kind of
joining yeah i think it is i think
to ask your question is the spectrum and
whether one should even take positions
in them
first of all i think
first we should clearly keep an open
mind
second
i think the fact that different
physicists
have slightly different viewpoints about
this is not a weakness of us as a
community but a strength because we will
all work harder on the things we're
excited about and it's much better that
we bark up many trees and then we all
bark up the same tree right and i think
i think you'll agree with me for
instance that
many extremely practical discoveries
that were made
which were useful and even made money
like computers
were made because someone had was really
passionate about some philosophical
question einstein was trying to
understand the nature of time i mean how
much more philosophical can you get
discovers this formula e equals mt
squared it gives us the nuclear power
which might be keeping these lights on
tonight you know very
down-to-earth practical discoveries come
from this curiosity
driven
desire for understanding so so i think
it's great that there's a spectrum and i
never try to persuade colleagues who are
psyched about a different part of it to
do other things because i think
you don't want some kind of ontological
monoculture we don't want everybody
running windows we want to have
different approaches here
well as a mac user i'll certainly agree
with that
but no i i i absolutely agree let me
distinguish between
two different kinds of
uh open-mindedness with respect to just
the question where we're asking and it
goes back to some of the things that
david has said there's seems to be
there's two ways of of categorizing the
different views that we have about
quantum mechanics one is
different interpretations of quantum
mechanics that give the same result your
many worlds interpretation is going to
give the same result as my shut up and
calculate interpretation
but it may be that one or the other or
any number of other ones that give the
same results will yield different
insights
and allow us to make progress
that wouldn't have been possible had we
stuck with one particular uh
interpretation and that's very important
to have different ways of looking at
things and as you say have different
people barking up different trees
but to me even more exciting and that's
already really exciting but even more
exciting is different interpretations of
quantum mechanics that predict different
things because then i come into play you
see i'm
the odd man out here i'm the only
experimentalist i'm the guy who works in
the lab and tests these things i'm the
real quantum mechanic the guy who's got
the wrenches and the uh i thought a
quantum mechanic was a little thing that
go guy with a little wrench fixing a
machine the nano machine you need a
quantum mechanic
so so if somebody predicts something
that is different from what quantum
mechanics predicts then i'm really happy
because i can go in the lab and i can
find out whether that's right or not and
you know what gives an experimentalist
the greatest pleasure
to prove that the theorists are wrong
so it doesn't matter someone's going to
end up being wrong
so that means no matter what it's going
to work out well for me
because if there's two theories and
they're different then one of them's
wrong
and i'm going to find out if i'm clever
enough or at least that my graduate
students are clever enough
but you know
we i'm swedish and we love to say bad
things about danish people
and
the reason that many physicists refer to
the copenhagen fog when they describe
niels bohr was because he was
deliberately vague on some things and
it's not even clear whether what he
predicted was always right because he
said this applies to atoms and if you
really pushed him and said is it going
to apply to something with 10 to the 15
atoms
there are some things he published which
suggests that he thought it didn't even
apply right and that's something you can
now start the test you can start
there are these beautiful experiments
trying to put little
mechanical cantilevers in in
superpositions and quantum computers and
you everett right who's died who's
published this idea 50 years ago about
many worlds he made a very firm
prediction saying that quantum mechanics
is going to apply to your experiment no
matter how big it is and therefore
quantum computers are ultimately doable
he laid
down his prediction
whereas maybe the copenhagen fog said
you know just don't answer that question
and i prefer people who at least
will have the guts to just make a firm
prediction that you can falsify yeah and
there are people who are predicting that
i can't make a quantum computer with
more than about 400 bits and you're
probably aware of these these these
ideas that say there just isn't enough
information in the universe to be
contained in a fully entangled
400 bit uh object well 400 bits
i mean so far we've done maybe two okay
this is what's known as a two-bit
quantum computer
thank you very much thank you you'll be
back ladies and gentlemen
you'll be taking orders afterwards but
it's it's you know but but 400 isn't
that much different from two
and so it's about 3.98
but you know
i mean i'm i'm optimistic that maybe
within my lifetime i'll be able to make
something with 400 entangled i bet a lot
of us are wondering the same thing what
how do you go about entangling a couple
of particles just like you have about
five seconds okay so so so the particles
i work with are atoms okay and the way
i'm going to entangle them is i'm going
to put this one into uh a superposition
being up and down this is this ordinary
uh quantum uncertainty that we've been
talking about and uh and then i'm going
to
uh bring it in contact with another atom
where the the force between the atoms
depends on whether this thing is up or
down
and then something's going to happen to
this other atom because the force is
different then i'm going to pull them
apart and now
what the state of this atom is going to
depend on what the state of this atom is
in this funny
spooky action at a distance way so the
way i do it in practice is i've got a
little container for atoms and i've got
one atom here and one atom here and i
know exactly how to put this one into
the superposition stage it sounds weird
but i do it every day huh okay so i've
got it now in this superposition state
this thing there i don't know which way
it is when you say it's in superposition
you mean it's in a lot of states at once
or it's indeed two states in one it's in
those two states at the same time at the
same time it's all ready i'm gonna get
one yeah of the answers but i have no
idea which it's gonna be then i've got
this other atom over here and i've got a
container for it and then i bring the
two containers together and i do this
all with what you mean all you have to
do is bring them into physical proximity
and and any but these are any two atoms
no i mean i have to choose the right
atom that has the right properties that
that the force depends on what the state
is and uh so i can't just use any guard
in other words you have to read the
manual yeah that's right and so that's
what you've done
we've we've figured it out and we
figured out well we can do this with
rubidium atoms and we use some tricks
that i don't want to talk about no but
there are children here that's right but
you know we use we use exchange right
for the for the the for the people who
are the cognoscenti and we bring them
together and they come apart and they're
entangled
and it's not very hard you got that
well i mean it's it's not very hard to
do the the key thing with entanglement
is the state of this thing depends upon
what the state of this one is going to
be even though i have no idea what the
state of either one is but when you when
you open one box up then i know what the
other one is you know what the other
one's going to be now here's the thing
that really i think weirded einstein out
was that that he says look here's
something okay and
here's a particle it's sitting over here
it's in the box when i open up the thing
i'm going to find that it's either up or
down
now
if i have any kind of a notion
that uh that the world works in the way
i think it does then what it means is
before i open the box then it must be
that that thing was in the state up or
down that i'm going to see when i open
it up
and if that's true
then this business about entanglement
has to be crap
and it turns out i mean so what einstein
was hoping was that the business about
entanglement was going to be crap but
what it turned out was and there's
experiments that show this and that's
the amazing thing let's come back to the
experiments that if you say i've got a
thing here
and this thing here has a property and
that property exists before i look at it
if you insist that that's true you're
wrong
now that sounds like the most reasonable
thing you could imagine that a thing
sitting here has a property that exists
before i measure it but we now know that
at least is wrong you'd agree with that
right that part is wrong now whether
some grander idea of reality is right or
not that remains to be seen but at least
that idea of reality the thing sitting
here
has a property before i measured we know
that's wrong
can i just amplify that that point
because it's a really important one so
so just to put it in more familiar terms
what some people suggested was well you
know when you measure and you find this
one's up and that's down or this is up
and that's down what's really going on
is much like a pair of gloves okay you
have a right glove and a left glove and
let's say you put them down you pick one
up you don't know which one you picked
up you put one in one box you take the
other you put another box you bring the
boxes to the other sides of the country
when you open this one up and you see
right you immediately know that one's
left is that mysterious not really
not at all
so people thought maybe that's what's
really going on with these yeah but it
sounds like i mean we're let me just i'm
sorry i thought you were going to go
so so what we learned is that that's not
right so the gloves themselves are
somehow always in this mixture
even before you look they are in that
mixture they're not in right-handed or
left-handed before you look so if you
open up you find right it wasn't right
before you looked
more or less we learned although there
are ways of interpreting this which are
more subtle than that you actually still
have to accept that things were in this
mixture before you looked
and that is a very strange reality to
buy into that but that's what we're
forced into that's what i was going to
ask you and it sounds like
you're describing something truly spooky
in that
it's not just a question of having
packed and forgetting where you put the
right glove or the left glove right
somehow we're suggesting you're
suggesting that until you open one of
those suitcases
up it could be either the right or the
left it's not that it no it that it's
neither that it that that it's you know
the standard view of this
is that
um it's in a situation
for which asking whether it's the right
glove or the left glove
just somehow doesn't make sense it's
like asking
like
it's like asking
it's like asking whether a tuna sandwich
is a democrat or a republican
um
it just
it it just doesn't make sense on on the
on the standard view now they're they're
um
that doesn't rule out at all
that there's some story about what's
really going on there if i have
something in a box and i ask is the
thing in this box a democrat or a
republican and the thing in the box
turns out to be a tuna sandwich
you find out that the question was
inappropriate okay
it doesn't mean that there's no reality
about what's going on there it means
that the reality was very different from
the one you were assuming when you
raised the question in the way you did
it's one thing to say looks like we've
got a big challenge here it looks like
we're going to have to radically
reconceive our picture of the world in
order to tell a coherent story about
what's going on here it's quite another
thing to say as board did the thing to
learn from this
is that
reality is a bad and dangerous word to
be using altogether you know
when when those of us in the the lay
world hear
these amazing descriptions of reality
it's very easy for us to say and i know
people who say this well you seem to
indicate that anything is possible
and and
quantum physics is weird
so
someone finds it easy to say
i just thought of something weird so
that's probably reality too
now i know that's a logical it's an
illogicality however it when you hear so
many weird things it's and we don't have
the tools with which to test these
statements ourselves because we either
don't have the mat or we don't have the
machines and the experimental equipment
it's very hard for us
to
to not start drifting in our thinking
into
um anything goes kind of thought what
what what can save us from that
well i think one thing that you always
have to keep in mind which we have
discussed before is that however weird
quantum mechanics is and however strange
a reality it might be revealing to us
it makes these very specific definite
predictions
of fantastic accuracy when compared to
experiment and most things that you
dream up in your head
don't do that
and that's the critical distinction
right can i just ask bill one question
because i'm really curious about this
when you say that you like this shut up
and calculate approach
i'm wondering the following if i came
upon a box
and i gave you this box it had this
miraculous property that any question
you asked it it could give you the
answer to anything what will happen when
i throw this particle against this what
will happen had the universe begin all
the answers pop out
would you feel that was time to
retire
because all the answers would be there
or would you feel the need to i want to
open the box and figure out how it's
doing that i want to know the reality
that this box is using to yield these
answers
well absolutely in fact if you had a box
like that then one thing it could tell
me is where the electron ends up when i
put it through the the double slit and
if it could do that then it means
quantum mechanics is wrong which is
fantastic but let's say it didn't do
that
wouldn't you still feel the need to
probe the inner workings so when you say
shut up and calculate the sense of it's
giving me the answers and that's good
enough so you're absolutely right
so when i i
take the shut up and calculate view one
of the reasons why i was presenting it
was because i wanted to make sure that
the orthodox view was presented among
all of these heretics that are here on
the uh
on on the stage but one of the things
that i think is true both of my view the
shut up and calculate view and of all of
these other views except for ones that
aren't quantum mechanics
is that they're unsatisfying they're
fundamentally unsatisfying and the
genius of einstein was he realized in a
deeper way
i believe than most of his
contemporaries
how
unsatisfying quantum mechanics was and
the reason we're having these kinds of
discussions is that each one of us
feels unsatisfied by quantum mechanics
as it stands now and each one of us has
our own reaction to that dissatisfaction
and i'm not satisfied with any of those
reactions well so many of us have
different
different thresholds of satisfaction
some people can be satisfied believing
that the world sits on the back of a
turtle and they're perfectly happy with
that and other people need to go much
deeper and other people need as einstein
did to go
way beyond what anybody told them was
the actual fact and that it's uh
but and yet as we search out for these
different reasons the different
solutions to our curiosity
we it's it's amazing how we come up with
these different answers and
and we are barking up different trees
and that is
very satisfying to us as a group as a
community as a species it's really
delicious
we're going to have to wrap up now and i
want to thank brian greene and dave
albert
and and and bill phillips and max tag
mark and i want to thank the the sponsor
of tonight's program
which is supporting the big ideas series
at the festival the john templeton
foundation but i want to ask one last
question as we as we wrap up a quick one
one that we
you probably can answer this in a couple
in one or two sentences the question is
do you think that there's something
fundamental
missing in the in the notion of quantum
physics are we going to 100 or 200 years
from now look back on this time and say
gee how naive they were then they they
really didn't get it they were missing
this fundamental thing or does it does
it really capture it
in a satisfying way that will continue
to be satisfying what do you think let's
go down the front line i mean i feel
very strongly that a few hundred years
from now we'll look back at this time
and recognize there were things that we
were missing
and moreover i think there's a
possibility that when some of those
missing pieces are filled in
quantum mechanics may not seem quite as
strange as it does now i mean you know
when we talk about you know in the old
days people thought that the the sun
went around the earth and then we got
really clever and realized that the
earth goes around the sun no no there's
a sense in which the sun goes around the
earth we see it happening it's a
perspective it's an awkward one it's an
ineffective one it's an efficient one
but by god it's one that's defensible
but it's much more
transparent description of the world to
put the sun at the center and take the
sun's perspective i think there may be
another perspective which when we have
that vantage point quantum mechanics
becomes much more transparent
david how about you i mean i guess um um
i i agree with what brian says the the
only thing i would add to it is i think
there's a certain respect in which
we've already seen the beginnings of a
development
like that that is i think
um
[Music]
it's happened in the past 20 years or so
that
that
there has that that
there's been a disaffection
with being told
um we're not supposed to ask these sorts
of questions there's been a disaffection
with being told that reality isn't the
sort of notion that you should take too
seriously and we now have
a couple of models on the table
maybe they're just worth mentioning one
of them is the many worlds
interpretation that max has been talking
about
the other is a whole collection of what
are called hidden variables theories of
quantum mechanics the most successful of
those
is is one due to a physicist named david
baum
and there's a whole collection of what
of
of what are called theories of the
collapse of the wave function the most
successful of those i think is one due
to three italian physicists gerardi
romanian weber um
um we're studying these things now these
are things which
have in common
that they are not in the business of
ruling out any questions these are
things that have in common that what
they purport to offer you is an account
all the way down to the bottom of what's
really going on an account which not
merely allows you to do the calculations
correctly but tells you why those are
the why those are the correct
calculations to do so
i i think this already represents an
enormous amount of progress it may well
be it probably will be because this is
usually the way it happens in science
that a hundred years from now we'll look
back on these theories as we always look
back on our scientific theories of a
long time ago and they'll look
silly they'll look naive we'll have much
better ways of putting them but a big
watershed has already been crossed in
embarking on the business of theorizing
about this
at all
bill how about it well let me give two
answers to the question one about
whether they're
is one of them going to be in this world
at least
so so one the question is to will we
look back and and imagine that we've
been incredibly naive well today i've
already got students who think that
these kinds of discussions are
incredibly naive in other words they are
not bothered
by quantum mechanics and i think it's in
part because they didn't absorb the
culture of classical mechanics very well
and quantum mechanics just doesn't seem
strange to them they're perfectly happy
with it so we already now that's not
what you're looking for at all
but but this group of of of students who
have grown up playing video games
instead of hitting baseballs right are
not uh weirded out by quantum mechanics
so that's one observation and what's the
other the other so so the other
observation is i have a bet with a
colleague who is a professor here at nyu
his name is ben peterson that in 50
years
we will have experimental evidence that
we can know things that quantum
mechanics tells us we can't know
now i've taken the side of the bet that
says quantum mechanics will prevail and
ben has taken the side of the bet that
says that quantum mechanics will fall
and we'll
end up learning experimentally that
there's something we can know
i sure hope that ben wins the band
thanks how about it where which which
side of the bet would you be i think you
200 years from now
people will look back and feel satisfied
about quantum mechanics and i think
that's
because they will have changed
their idea of what they should be
satisfied by see if you take
this mathematically very simple elegant
theory where there's just this one
hilbert space it's evolving
deterministically
except of course within it there's this
big reality with many
parallel worlds there's been a big shift
already in the last 10 years i think
at conferences to how people react 10
years ago most of my colleagues would
say
this makes no sense and i hate it
and now they say
this makes no sense
and i love it i blew it actually i meant
to say now they say
i hate it
which means they're not satisfied and
the crook says what the reason they're
not satisfied of course is because it
doesn't agree with their intuition but
but think about this
charles darwin told us that we evolved
to have intuition for the kind of stuff
which was useful for ancestors or we
have a great intuition for baseball
because our ancestors threw a lot of
rocks yeah and if they didn't have
intuition for the classical physics of
how those would move they would get
cleaned right out of the gene pool which
is which is where we started our
conversation but
this also makes a prediction an
experimental prediction actually which
may should make you happy darwin if he
was more interested in physics could
have predicted that whenever we used
clever technology to probe things which
our ancestors
had no awareness of we should find our
intuition breaking down and look what
happened you look measure what happens
when you go near the speed of light time
slows down is that intuitive uh uh then
you start looking at really really big
things and they turn into black holes
totally counterintuitive this summer
we're opening up the biggest particle
smasher ever built in geneva it's going
to smash protons together and
out will come higgs bosons and perhaps
and w bosons and all that maybe
maybe it is and it's just like smashing
together two apples
time has gone by way too fast no we've
got to so the bottom line i have to say
is just that we should expect the
correct theory to seem weird and we
should be satisfied by that
okay
i hope let me
let me thank you i'm sorry i'd interrupt
you
it's been a wonderful conversation i uh
we
i would have liked and i'm sure we all
would have liked to have gone all night
but you have to go home when you get to
your cars that you some of you will go
into your own car send it to somebody
else's car
it's it's been a wonderfully weird
evening i don't know if the universe
seems any less weird to you but i hope
you're a little more comfortable with
weirdness because it looks like we're
going to get plenty of it from now on
thank you and good night thank you